I believe the children are children
they're not old enough to have the
perspective that adults do no tragedy
and age don't confer any sort of
expertise on a given issue quote a
lesbian skinhead
[Music]
this was make your student protest day
it's theater children are the future
just make sure they don't have a say in
it
the mobilised students of Marjory
Stoneman Douglas high have inspired the
entire country and while we wait on
legislators to pass meaningful gun
control why not pass something else in
the meantime to show these students that
we care about them and their concerns
like lowering the voting age here's why
16 year olds voting could be good for
democracy ever since a gunman killed 17
students with an ar-15 in parkland
Florida survivors have done a whole lot
more than think and pray they've gone on
national TV and mobilize people around
the country to protest walk out do
sit-ins and diane's and even have the
guts to confront their pro-gun senator
face to face
senator Rubio can you tell me right now
that you will not accept a single
donation from the NRA
he couldn't unlike pretty much every
other mass shooting where Americans get
shamed for talking about gun control
until we forget it ever happened
these students are making sure that the
country does not forget about them how
long do you think you will keep doing
this we're Millennials and we love
complaining more than any other
generation this generation it's used to
get answers right away you think they're
gonna wait for six month or a year for
anybody in Congress or any anybody that
needs to make the right call yeah in a
way
you think patience and entitlement is
paying off brilliantly think about it
these teens have never had to wait for
an answer they couldn't immediately get
from Google while ordering a pizza from
a nap and facetiming a crush in Oregon
they made out with one time at summer
camp you think they have the time to
wait to get weapons of war out of their
schools um to them gun control should be
as easy as the Domino's app hold the
bump stock side of registries hey you
guys want extra background checks but
because they're just a bunch of
with no political clout some are
wondering why they should be taken into
consideration at all just listen to
Florida lawmaker Elizabeth Porter as she
argued against the parklands students
demands for gun reform we've been told
that we need to listen to the children I
do what the children ask are there any
children on this floor are there any
children making laws do we allow the
children to tell us that we should pass
a law that says no homework
the adults make the laws because we have
the age we has the wisdom and we have
the experience well we we has the wisdom
way to instill confidence trust us we
has wrote in the laws before cuz we is
the lawyers and we are gonna bring you
logis Latian and the idea that teens
can't vote so who cares about them was
echoed by a guy who was just told he
can't eat crayons anymore tucker carlson
so if they're too young to buy guns why
should they be making my gun laws they
are not making your gun laws there
they're not of eighteen they're
Americans look but they don't have the
full rights of citizenship because
they're not adults they can't drink
alcohol that a lot of them can't drive
cars you don't want them to buy guns in
the air boat plus everyone knows that
bullets can only hurt you when you turn
18 you know it's amazing where his
empathy ends is just where his stupidity
begins he truly is a douchebag carousel
and yet he and Elizabeth has the wisdom
Porter managed to bring up an
interesting point most teens can't vote
but they are old enough to be shot at
and died not to mention own rifles and
shotguns in 30 states so maybe the
question is should teens be able to vote
why not lower the voting age to 16 in
most national elections around the world
like the u.s. you have to be 18 to vote
but in some countries it is 16 including
Austria Brazil and Argentina and in 2014
beginning with their vote on
independence Scotland began allowing 16
year-olds to vote for the simple reasons
stated by this lawmaker if we're
prepared to send people young people to
the front line under needs to take their
taxes why should they not indeed have a
say in what is basically about their
future and that makes sense a lot of
teams work and pay taxes
and the injustice of being able to fight
in a war that you don't have a say in is
exactly why President Nixon signed the
26th amendment into law which lowered
the voting age from 21 to 18 and the
sick reality is that today with the
amount of school shootings it's almost
as if the wars have come home at least
the weapons have so why not lower the
voting age again three towns in Maryland
have already allowed 16 year olds to
vote in local elections and yet every
time the debate crops up you always hear
the same argument I know kids in this
age group and they are dumb as dirt when
it comes to politics
I wouldn't put them in charge of their
allowance I remember how I was at 16 and
I couldn't have voted for a dog catcher
I was so naive young people are stupid
have you ever spoken to them if we let
them vote they're gonna vote for the
party guy in the Hawaiian shirt sure and
when we let adults vote they vote for
the guy in the baseball hat who needs a
cheat sheet to show sympathy remember
this is the generation that had to sit
on the sidelines as the country elected
a corrupt reality TV star with no
political experience and if their
parents couldn't protect them from that
why should they trust them to take care
of them at all for all kids no there is
a monster living under their beds and
masturbating actually improves eyesight
maybe part of the reason teens are seen
as not caring about things that affect
them is that adults keep telling them
they're too stupid and too young to care
about things that affect them when the
reality is they do care just ask this
seventeen-year-old who campaigned to
lower the voting age in San Francisco it
really matters to me when funding for
parts gets changed it really matters to
me when the minimum wage gets changed
and that affects my community our
country actually has a history of smart
politically active teens like in the 60s
when teenagers and children marched in
Birmingham to protest segregation or the
15 year old who recently developed a
system to detect early stages of
pancreatic cancer he explains why teens
are ready to make change teenagers were
at this epitome of creativity where it
can dream up wild ideas but we have
enough knowledge to make our ideas a
reality yes not to mention the knowledge
to make exquisite dishes every week on
master
chef jr. on the top you will see the
puff pastry and then under that you will
see the crepe and then you'll see the
mushroom duxelle the prosciutto and then
the meat okay but I make a mean bag of
Trader Joe's gyoza I cook by the way not
only is the discussion about lowering
the voting age patronizing and stacked
against teens but those who vote on
whether or not to lower the voting age
are already of voting age which is a
cruel catch-22 and also makes you wonder
who in these thirty states voted for the
age of consent to be 16 I'm gonna go out
on a limb and guess not 16 year olds and
having teens vote might mean good things
for democracy studies show voter turnout
is habitual so perhaps the earlier you
get someone to vote the more likely they
will later on one study even showed that
when young people vote their parents are
more likely to vote too in some ways
teens might be more equipped to vote
than adults think about it they just
went through the unit on how a bill
becomes a law where they're gam-gam just
went through a red light it makes sense
that entrenched political power would be
afraid of the youth vote because young
people tend to be open-minded and vote
liberal it's that crazy thing they have
what's it called hope polling and voting
trends suggest that if 16 year olds in
the UK had been allowed to vote whether
to exit the EU regs it wouldn't have
happened and in the 2016 US primary
election more than 2 million voters
under 30 voted for Bernie Sanders that's
more youth votes in the primary than
Clinton and Trump received combined Oh
Bernie what I won yet we shouldn't
assume that all young people are
necessarily liberal in Kansas 16 Agers
are running for governor because they
were smart enough to figure out that the
dumb adults who wrote the laws didn't
bother writing an age minimum to run and
only one is running as a Democrat the
deep state globalist shill no matter
what side of the political spectrum
they're on the one thing all teens have
that adults lack is the ability to not
give a fuck about Authority one of the
best things about our generation sure
people think we're lazy and on our
phones all the time we don't respect you
just because you have senator in front
of your name and that's really helpful
in pointing out the bull around things
like gun laws what do you think about
this idea of arming teachers it's stupid
why
Douglas ran out of paper for a lake
two weeks in the school year and now all
of a sudden they have four hundred
million dollars to pay for teachers to
get trained to arm themselves really
really teens are the realest and
considering the world they've been
handed with massive inequality rising
sea levels and a president who the nra
spent 30 million dollars to elect
perhaps we should make it easier for
them to have a say in the world they're
supposed to inherit to all of the
generations before us we sincerely
accept your apology and we we appreciate
that you are willing to let us rebuild
the world that you fucked up hmm
so if conservatives are so upset by
teens in the streets demanding their
rights give them the right to vote and
if they manage to pass laws banning
ar-15s or banning homework more power to
them cuz it will have meant that in a
way they did their homework thanks again
for watching news broke I'm Francesca
fiorentina follow me on Twitter at
Frannie Pheo and follow news broke on
Facebook watch if you're still on
Facebook after everything that's
happened subscribe to us on YouTube
there you go that's a good idea also you
can get this shirt right here
stormy 2020 from our friends at brand
marinade at shop or cha de armado calm
and you can get our original t-shirt
which is of the or Chadha Armada you
know the Tea Party of the left see you
next week